hails of guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 109 I'm game
programming and open forever but I have
been swamped down with University
assignments and I just didn't have time
making episodes but but today I decided
to and the reason is but from there's
been a long time is because the first
episode of game programming had 200,000
views recently and 5,000 likes and I had
28 thousand subscribers today so I
thought you know what it's probably time
to actually continue this YouTube thing
so here we are and today we're gonna
talk about continuing to draw form
because we didn't do that last time now
if you guys were watching the previous
episodes which of course I recommend
that you do if you're watching this one
now we started doing a font shade we
actually finished the font rate well I
think I did that outside of the episode
but um we made this font sheet and we're
gonna actually render it onto the screen
that's our goal so if we were on the
game right now it looks pretty much the
same as it always did did you can shoot
you can removes everywhere whatever but
we want to actually be able to write a
text onto the screen okay that's our
goal right now now um one of the things
that we have to do right is expand this
font class that we've got to incorporate
some kind of rendering capability and
have actually rendered the characters
that we've load okay I know it's been a
while so I might just go over this code
just a bit what we did is we made a
split method this is like a previously
kinda thing but what we do is what we
did is we made like a split method here
that you guys can see and essentially
what this does is it splits up
spreadsheet into X amount of sprites
okay and then returns them has an array
and then over here in sprite sheet I
don't think we'd editing in spreadsheet
nope okay and then um over here in font
in game just check that it works we
saturated the class so that these static
fields would actually be instantiated
and it gave us my arrows okay and if you
actually look at the console I think it
loaded the herald PNG I actually changed
the name of that because it was just
real okay if you're on that of course
it'll do failed because we did add we
did add that error checking
functionality last time but well it will
change it back to aerial of course
because that is the name of this PNG
file
we've got okay fantastic so let's get
this onto the screen now this is
actually a pretty cool little thing
that's going on here that you guys are
not aware of but what I'm just gonna
show you guys this in a minute but the
idea is let's focus on how to actually
make the font class render things okay
it's pretty simple all right we actually
have in our screen class but remember
screen is our rendering class all right
screen is the class that has the pixels
that will eventually be put onto our
window okay onto our screen so whatever
we actually want to physically
manipulate pixels on the screen we use
the screen class form okay so clearly
it's gonna have it's gonna play a role
in this now I thought about making a
render font or a render of character
kind of like writing a letter render
number but altogether render character
not like a character like a mob but a
character like a letter or number I
thought about making a random character
method but you know what I think we need
to because we've already got this render
sprite method okay
one of the things this render sprite
method does not do is do any kind of
alpha checking okay and what I mean by
that is the fake alpha that we've got
going on wear pink basically we just
don't render so we might have to add
that in somehow but let's actually focus
on getting the letters onto the screen
with the pink stuff okay just for now so
we'll make a public void render okay and
all we'll type in right now screen
screen okay that's it I'm gonna keep
this really simple and then we'll just I
guess we'll just type in screen don't
render sprite okay where we want it
let's just say 5050 the sprite that will
render for now will be the first
character so character zero okay
sorry character zero referring to this
array of sprites of course so we run
running the first bright in the array
which should be the letter A all right
and fixed we'll set the equal to false
that means that it'll be floating around
so it'll actually be at 50/50 not 50/50
in the level but 50/50 on our screen
okay now we don't want font here okay we
want font out here now very very
important that you don't leave it like
this okay do not instantiate this as a
field right here okay it will not work
in fact I'll prove it to you because I
think if you people were asking me this
if I run this right now we'll get a
crash okay and if we look at it it'll be
pointer exception and what will actually
happen is if we trace this down a bit
I'm sorry this work areas bit mm bit
small but somewhere in sprite shape for
example yeah we'll have all this stuff
and you can say I'll play it down we
instantiate it to play a bit hang on a
minute hover your mouse over it oh
that's not why is it null because we
haven't actually instantiated these
fields yet okay you have to not do it
this way okay well not work this way
because note that when we launch it this
way right what actually happens is if we
trace this back all the way down that
code this font font equals new font
wherever that here it is this font font
equals new font will run when we
actually create a new game instance okay
that's when it will get called that's
before we've even created our thread or
side of that game okay that's why it's
crashing that's why it's not working so
you need to make sure that you cut out
this equals new font part okay and put
it let's terminate that of course and
put it somewhere in the constructor for
example okay this is where we
instantiate everything and we do that
for a reason not just for fun okay so
I'm gonna put it right here font font
equals new font okay
will the game class have a font probably
not okay but we're testing fonts of this
at this point in time so yep okay great
so you know that's out of the way let's
try and render something okay well let's
try and called a random method in font
and font class to render something we'll
do it after we render the level okay
so font don't render screen will just be
screen okay so that should now call this
random method which in turn should
render the sprite which should feel the
appropriate pixels at our screen with
the pixels in character okay in in the
first character let's run that all right
we're gonna crash right now where is
this in is it still in this is Lord okay
say it's telling us how she doesn't know
okay so let's go back to game let's
crawl up to font okay let's bring this
font down a bit okay just to about maybe
after player all right and we'll run it
okay this time we don't get the crash
notice that okay that's probably because
player is actually the first class to
use a spreadsheet or a sprite okay
that's why everything gets instantiated
okay so I think if we put this above
player we'll probably get the crash no
you weren't okay let's try bit higher
all right there we go so we have to do
it after level okay because level don't
spawn instantiates that stuff honestly
I'm just gonna put it probably all the
way up to play can't that seemed to work
pretty well so where's our font well I
just do where I move there let's put
font below player all right ten minute
yes let's run that okay we get plus
weird isn't it right we just when we the
first character that should be 0 right
if we bring up plus so if we're putting
up our character map here I guess font
shape we've got the plus as the last one
so what's going on like maybe the baby's
reversed let's just try something like
characters too okay whoa that's the same
plus sign what is going on okay and I by
the way I know exactly what's going on
I'm just gonna trying to show you guys
what's actually going on okay so that
means that all of these are equal right
what if I try 50 or 69 i don't knoe
swear that wasn't an accident by the way
I wasn't looking at my keyboard so we've
got plus as well okay what's going on
here well one way to actually chance to
save this is actually accurate
let's just print out the oops let's just
print out the actual characters right
okay all actually that would be stupid
let's actually print out the hashcode
okay for that so if we print this out
we're getting what is that 48 okay well
48 54 whatever let's change this oh look
it is different right 35 so just it's an
actual different sprite all these are
different sprites
but for some reason they're the same
value okay and this is one of those
errors where if you don't know a javo
need or no low-level kind of Java you
will have no idea what's going on okay
you will have zero idea what's going on
okay but luckily I do know what's going
on because otherwise this would be a
interesting problem to solve okay
it has to do with how Java passes array
is basically through certain parameters
okay so if we go to sprite shape sorry
we're gonna if where's our sparkle Oscar
okay basically let's just go to font
okay for control click on sprite I'll
split it will take you to that method
let's take a look at this and this is
very subtle
okay this error what happens here as
weeks we create the new pixels array
yeah what we do is we then you know we
basically sort through every character
in this right we grab the pixels from
every character in that in that font
shade and we extract every pixel of that
character over here right and we
actually put it into this pixel array
and then we pass the pixel array through
the parameter here we pass it into the
constructor for new sprite so that
actually creates the new sprite based on
those pixels with the width and height
of course of the character and it puts
that into this sprites array and then it
increments the current variable here so
that the next time it does that it puts
it on to the next sprite in the arraign
Alex fine right if we go back to the mm
what happens is of course we get to the
end of this it goes back to the
beginning of this loop over here and it
does it again and okay it's overriding
the pixels and it's passing them in
through parameters so what's the issue
here well we don't have pointers in Java
okay so what happens is and people are
like well we don't have pointers so that
means everything's like how does that
make okay we do have pointers in Java
okay we can't just we actually can't
define them they're there obviously
otherwise otherwise basically this would
be an unusable language so what Java
does is it actually and this is a bit of
a Java tutorial and honestly in a way
but I really want you guys to get this
what job it does is it assumes pointers
in some kind of case okay so values
sorry objects or well things let's just
say things are passed by you know when
we pass things in through a parameter
like this okay there's two ways Java
traits then okay it is a it either
passes it by value or passes it by
reference okay
value means that it physically just
passes in the value is if we just hit
five okay so for example for integers
for any kind of primitive data type
strings all that stuff they are passed
by value
okay so it means if we created in X
we've a set it equal to zero we passed
an X through here in the in the sprite
constructor we'll have our own version
of X okay we won't it won't have
anything to do with this version it
simply just grabs the value 0 it passes
in 0 and then whatever we do in the the
constructor stays that way okay however
objects and arrays or even arrays of
primitive types like arrays of integers
in this case our pixels array that stuff
is passed by reference okay what does
that mean passed by reference means that
it doesn't actually kind of it doesn't
copy it across it doesn't give it a
different version it actually just links
it okay it points to it so what happens
is when we put pixels into here you can
see in sprite we simply set this doc
pixels equals pixels what we're doing is
we're actually setting the memory
address of our pixels equal to the same
pixels that we passed in through the
parameter okay over here so what happens
is when we then go ahead and change that
pixel array right which is what happens
when we get at the end when we go ahead
and we obviously reassign each of these
pixels it actually changes in all the
instances of sprite so they all have
these same pixels okay if you get really
really kind of Detective II that's even
a word and you pull out like something
like visual VM or some kind of Java
profiling check and check a look at the
memory usage you'll see that there's
only one array of pixels okay for sprite
there's not copies of the of it okay so
what happens in in in summary I guess is
we're not actually making a copy of
these pixels when we go ahead and
override them there's only one in its
kind of like pixels is static in a way
right that's probably the best way to
describe it if you guys know what the
static means it's like pixels of static
okay so when we put them into sprite and
we go ahead back to it and we change
them it changes the ones already in the
sprites that we've created okay whereas
we want each sprite to have its own set
of pixels so what we need to do there is
either force it to pass by value which
is impossible because Java does not have
pointers so we can't not use pointers
one because what is doing here is
basically using a pointer right it's
passing by reference we want to pass by
value
we can't do that okay this isn't C or
C++ unfortunately instead of what we can
do is force it to copy okay so in sprite
what we essentially need to do is
instead of setting pixels equal to
pixels we actually need to copy across
each individual integer into this pixel
array okay we could do that using a for
loop okay and I'll show you guys how
that would look like I is less than
pixels dot length okay I plus plus we
have to make sure that we actually
create this stop pixels equals new int
and then of course it would just be
width times height
or in this case we couldn't literally
just say pixels at length and then what
we did what we would have to do here is
just simply set this top pixels I equals
two pixels I all right let's get rid of
that last Amy okay so what we're doing
here is we're copying each individual
integer across okay so if we do run that
let's go back to fonts if it's back to
zero let's run it look at that we get a
letter A now okay
if I change this to one we should get
two sorry B and we do get B okay so you
can see that this error is pretty subtle
okay that's one way to do it we could do
a copy using this the other way which
you could use is something called system
dot or a copy okay so the source
basically I'll show you guys how to do
it this way in case you want to because
it is one line of code instead of three
but some basically the source right this
is what you're copying from so just
pixels being the parameter pixels the
position zero because you want to start
it from the start the destination being
the pixels that were copying into so
this stop pixels the destination
position we want we want to start
pasting basically at zero and then the
length of course pixel dot length okay
and if I get rid of that for a second
and run this you'll see that we get the
exact same result be still shows up and
not Plus okay whereas what we had before
was this stop pixels equals pixels like
that all right and if we run that we'll
get that plus again all right so you can
see that that's a very subtle error a
lot of
probably would not have picked up on
that it didn't take me very long to pick
up on it luckily because I could imagine
spending hours and this it took me about
I don't know literally about 10 seconds
to realize once I looked at the
spritesheet and I saw that it was the
last one if plus had been the first one
somewhere in the middle it probably
wouldn't have come to me that quickly
but I saw the puzzles last one and I was
like yeah they're all the same basically
so very very subtle error this is why
it's important to know Java when you're
making games I'm actually not going to
use a system right copy method this
probably looks a bit more clear because
I am trying to make this programming
series as simple as I can but yeah
that's what we need to do okay basically
that's yeah so make sure that you do
that make that amendment there's nothing
wrong with the actual split method it's
just the way that we the way that we
passed us in okay the way that sprite
handles incoming pixels okay
yeah that's pretty much it guys next
episode we'll take a look at drawing
stuff onto this actually being able to
pass in a string such as you know hello
and being able to pick out which
characters we want for that and render
them onto the screen okay I'll try to
make me up at night now in the next
episode this week as well but I can't
promise anything but it is nearing the
end of the semester so they'll
definitely be more episodes in the
future and that flappy bird series will
start eventually don't worry I've just
barely got enough time to handle this
but anyway thanks for watching guys hope
you guys enjoyed that one thing I really
want you guys to do as well as if you
just didn't understand all this passed
by point pass by reference stuff feel
free to leave a comment below
right that's always a good place to do
it or you can obviously go to the forums
ok and if you fish with forums okay
which of course is the turn under comm
for slash forums if you just go to the
gender comm there'll be a forms that
make sure you log in or register first
in the game programming you guys can
make a post about about that now this
isn't exactly about game programming
okay so what I might do right now
actually as soon as I own this video is
make a section here just for job for
languages like for Java and C++ and so
that you guys can post related questions
on to dare okay because this isn't
really related to game programming some
more alleges how the language works okay
we wouldn't have to do that we wouldn't
to do that in C++ because by syphilis in
C++ since we have pointers everything is
passed by value by default and then if
we want to pass it by reference we have
to specify that explicitly okay whereas
Java assumes things because well we call
these pointers unfortunately that's the
idea okay so make sure that you guys
understand that I don't think they'll be
much more of that in the future in this
series in terms of having to know really
detailed things like that but yeah you
can see here it came in handy so yeah go
ahead make a post on the forums you guys
having trouble with anything really I do
offer tutoring okay basically well so
the people have had it they say it's
really good but the idea is if you guys
want me to teach you privately like
basically like this video but what you
actually want to learn then you can go
ahead and fill out this form over here
pick the duration and stuff of the
tutorial pick a time or I'm available
which is not much but and then just just
go ahead and submit all right
so pretty simple and the idea is it's
kind of like a lot of people ask what
they're like I don't want to really
explain that too much in this video but
essentially I add you on skype I call
you I use TeamViewer so that you can see
my screen and then it's like I'm doing a
tutorial but specifically for you you
guys go ahead and into you know everyone
goes ahead and interrupts me ask
questions I answered them we just have a
good time really honestly they're fun
for both parties I have a lot of fun
doing it and everyone really enjoys them
so if you guys do want to seriously
learn game development or programming
even if you guys don't know Java yeah
whatever I don't know why I'd be
watching episode 109 if you don't know
Java but I don't know C++ and you want
to kind of transition maybe you want to
bring the game we're going over the game
programming series over into C++ this is
of course one of the many things that I
can teach you all right anyway I'll
catch you guys soon be sure to hit the
like button if you enjoyed the video and
later
you